I WANTAUA NEWGREN.
ONTIONS  TO     . PREPAH BACK
>> KEATON, I
MY SPEECH TOTO ANSWEAT.S YES.
NOT ATN'T THINK THERE
WERE IRREGULARITIES IN THE0 ELE
FATEFU
I HAD CONCERNSHA
A DOZEN STATES THAT HAD
CHANGED THE RULES IN THEE OFCOVN
ELECTIONS.
BUT ONCERTIFIED
THE ELECTION, ONCE THE
CLEAR.NSTITU STATES CLEARLY ONS
VOTES ARE  AND COUNTEDVER JOINE
SAYS OPENED HAWE DID THAT.
NT THE AMERICAN PELE
TO KTHH RDID OUR DUTYT DA HE KE.
I KNOW T D
LECTION.
I WAS ON THEALLOT.
F TY HAS
BPA
CONSTITUTION.
WED ENOUGH OF DEMOCRATS
TRAMPLIN OL
WANTINCOURT, DO
WITH SECOND AMENDMENT,
TRAMPLE OUR RELIGIOUS E ANK E A
PARTY AND SAY TH WILL BE A
PARTY WHL MEWOMEN THAT AREEDICA
THE UNITED S
>> SALD TRUMP
SAYS HE IS INCLINED TO PDORS
ATTACKED T CAPITOL ON JAY 6th.,
PART OE SAME D CHAND T
WANT HANU.YOCO ANY
>>OUNON OF
VI ISSUED MA
SAID THOSE THAT FAILED TLDEDT E.
HAPPENED ON LLOW WHAT
HAPPEN AIN IUR
DEMOCRACY.
S BE DECISIONS
AN COUR LAHAVEO INTEREST O N OF
OROUR
THEYTO BE SWO
>> SIR, I WA
KINIGHT THMENT
RECENTLY INFORMED DONA'SAM T ISA
OF ATIO
MISHANG CLASSIFIED
I SHOULD Y WE CLEARED
LAST WEEK IN YOUR OWSE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THE NEWG
OFS IS A
VERY SERIOUS AND
WAS WHY S
UPON MYSELF TO REVIER VELATIONS
AND WE UNCOVERED SMALL NUMBE D D
DEPARTMENTE AND I'M FTER OUR FL.
>> DS CASE A
>>Y IS OCAT OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S CASE.
O HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY IS EQUAL TREATMENT
UNDER THE LAW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AN, YOT KNOW, WAS VERY TROUBLER
WHEN FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
W ST EXECUTED AT E HOME
A ERTHEDSTATES.
SURELY Y KTHE
SERVED ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. WHEN YOU AND I FIRST
HAD TO BDOYS LD HANDLED
MEME TICE THAT WE HAD
AS MATERIALS POTENTIALLY
Y WERE AT MY
HOME, THE S ONON
WHATN JOE
N  ALERT
MENT 8
LATER, THEY SHOWED HIS
OFFICE.
THAT'S NOTAL UNDERLAW, WE'VE TO
TWO.HEN ISN TIOBSTRUCTION, WHI.
IF THAIS SOMETHINGHAVE POSSIBL
.I MEAN, SEVERAL REASONLLYHEENTO
THNUMBERLD
THAT THE LY DE
E ARE HURTING, IMEAN T ARE LE RU
THE LIKES OFHIVE
WE HAVE A FLOOD ENNYNG I C
AN'S
KILLING YOUNG OPLE EVERY DAY.
CRIMEWAVE IN OUR
NOW MOREHAE OUINDING WWE CANE
TOGETHER.
>> ANDIR'R OFTH OON THE DEPARTM
THIND SION IN THE UN
ANT ME ALSSAY K IT
THE. AL
F CR OF JUIC
AND THSERIOUMATTERWHADY HAPPENE
PRESIDENT IN UNITED ST TERRIBLE.
I  DS BETTER OF
ND
WI INDICTMENT.
>> SIR CFY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I
>> OKAY. WITH REGARD TUNIQUE, L
CLASED BUSINESS
HAVING CIFDOCUMENTINMY RESIDEN
TY FOR IT.NO BUSINESNG RESIDENC
AS WL.ME WIT I WOULHEREWOULD BE
FORWWI
DRASTIC ANP
INDICTING A FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES. FWA M
OUR COUNTRY FORWARD AND RESTE N
WOULD Y PARDON HIM? AALD TRUMP
>>ELL, I DON'T WANT TOAKT PO
ELECTED PRESIDD BUEVE WE HAVE AG
ALLY BVE AAR ANDOULD HOPE RECNN
PU
AMERICAN PEOARE FACING.
RATHER THAN TALKING ABOUT THAT
I WANT T